if you're learning spanish i recommend
you check out spanish pod 101 which has
a library of thousands of audio and
video lessons for learners of all levels
click the link in the description or
visit langfocus.com spanishpod for a
free lifetime account and give it a try
with a language as widely spoken as
spanish there's bound to be some
variation in how it's spoken there are
differences in accent of course but also
differences in vocabulary and grammar
especially in more colloquial speech
this is definitely the case with chilean
spanish which is known as one of the
language's most unique varieties the
spanish brought their language to what
is now peru and then to what is now
chile in the 16th century when spain
conquered the inca empire which included
not only peru but also northern chile
chile was already populated by
indigenous people who spoke indigenous
languages including quechua and aymara
in the north and mapudo moon in the
south of course the subjugated peoples
were compelled to learn the language of
their colonizers spanish but their
native languages also influenced the
emerging chilean variety of the language
many of the spanish colonizers who
settled in chile were from andalusia in
southern spain which influenced chilean
spanish notably in its intonation waves
of immigration after the initial spanish
colonization also influenced chile and
spanish for example there was heavy
immigration from england in the north of
the country and germany and the south as
well as italy switzerland france and
other countries with the extremely arid
atacama desert in the north and with the
andes mountains to the east chile was
historically rather isolated and remote
which allowed chilean spanish to diverge
somewhat from other varieties and
develop its own flavor there are
significant differences in chilean
spanish depending on socioeconomic
background with some of its most
distinct features occurring mainly in
very informal speech which some chileans
look down on as the speech of poor
people in more formal speech chilean
spanish is firmly rooted in castilian
spanish but even formal publications and
media use some uniquely chilean idioms
and vocabulary pronunciation like latin
american spanish in general chilean
spanish features ceseo and
is the pronunciation of z and of c
before i or e as su rather than th as
it's pronounced in spain yes mo is the
pronunciation of y and double l with the
same sound
though the exact sound varies somewhat
depending on the accent most spanish
accents feature yes more these days
chilean spanish is known for aspiration
of the sound sa when it occurs before a
consonant or at the end of a word for
example esto
meaning french fries becomes papa fritta
this occurs in some other varieties of
spanish as well but in chilean spanish
it occurs in more context than in some
of those other varieties it should be
noted though that this aspiration is
mainly used in informal speech
especially in accents associated with
lower socioeconomic status
another feature is the illusion of
this happens in words that end with a
vowel plus d or b
the word for salty becomes salah
another example is this verb which means
was going through pasawa becomes
similarly there's the illusion of the
rhodic consonant before
when the rhodic sound occurs before the
sounds
it's omitted and the following consonant
is doubled for example the word for meat
carne becomes
and the word for brother hermano becomes
similar to the aspiration of s this
occurs in informal speech and is most
common in rural accents and those
associated with lower socioeconomic
status and that's also true for another
feature the replacement of the sound cha
with the sound she the name of the
country chile sounds like chile
another example is this verb form which
means something like did you catch or
did you know
sounds like
but when people try to avoid this
pronunciation it sometimes results in
hyper correction in particular for
foreign loan words for example sho
sounds like cho
sushi sounds like suchi
grammar one feature of chilean spanish
is bo sale the use of boss as the second
person singular subject pronoun instead
of tu with special verb conjugations
that agree with that pronoun but buseo
in chile is somewhat different from
boseo and other spanish-speaking
countries where it's used well first of
all the final s in boss is usually
aspirated but some of the conjugations
are also different as a rule of thumb
both saleo verb conjugations that end
with us elsewhere and with i in chile
and those that end with ace or ace end
with e in chile as a result the final s
is completely absent from chilean boseo
eres meaning you are becomes
meaning you were becomes
meaning you catch or you understand
becomes
check out this example sentence this
means if you have free time you can come
visit me
in chilean spanish
notice that tienes becomes tini in chile
and notice that podrias becomes podria
it's important to point out that boseo
is not always used in chilean spanish
and chilean spanish also has something
called verbal boseo in which poseo verb
conjugations are used but with the
subject pronoun tu another element of
chilean spanish grammar specifically in
varieties associated with lower
socioeconomic status is the doubling of
object clitic pronouns first in standard
spanish and then in chile and spanish
this means i'm going to give it to you
with a double object clitic it's
this includes reflexive object pronouns
this means i'm going to go with the
object clitics doubled it's
in informal speech the imperative form
of the verb is sometimes replaced with
the present indicative third-person
singular form for example here's a
standard spanish imperative sentence
meaning make your bed hastu the usual
imperative form of
meaning to do or make is us but in
chilean spanish asi is used
another feature of chilean spanish is
the use of the prefix they to emphasize
or intensify adjectives here's a
standard spanish sentence meaning this
game is really difficult
in chilean spanish you might hear este
huevos
notice that the prefix re is used
instead of muy
vocabulary some of the vocabulary used
in chile is not completely exclusive to
chile but is used in certain other latin
american countries as well for example
in chile the usual word for car is
which is also used in argentina bolivia
ecuador paraguay peru and uruguay the
word used in most other parts of latin
america is caro while koche is used in
spain
in chile the word for bus specifically
an inter-city bus is mikro this word is
also used in argentina as well as in
mexico city with the meaning of minibus
in other countries words like altobus
cameon or omnibus are used
in chile the word for computer is
computador a word that's also used in
colombia but in most other places in
latin america the usual word is
computadora in spain the word is
ordinador
some words are used exclusively or
almost exclusively in chilean spanish in
chile the word for light bulb is an
the most common word outside of chile is
bombilla which refers to a drinking
straw in chile
in chile the word for a t-shirt is
bolera outside of chile the usual word
is camiseta in chile this refers to an
undershirt rather than a t-shirt
in chile a baseball cap is referred to
as a joki outside of chile the usual
word is gora or gora de basibol
there are a number of words for toilet
in the spanish language one of them
being retrete the chilean spanish word
is what or alternatively
literally bowl of the bathroom
one special element of chilean spanish
vocabulary is its loan words from
indigenous languages which are normally
used in addition to native spanish words
with a similar meaning the general
spanish word for baby is baby in chilean
spanish there's the word
which comes from the quechua and imada
word for baby
this is also used in bolivia ecuador and
some parts of colombia and peru
in general spanish the word for
boyfriend is novio and the word for
girlfriend is novia the chilean spanish
words are polulo for boyfriend and
polola for girlfriend estes mi polola
carla this is my girlfriend carla these
words come from the mapudengun word
pyulyu which means acting like a fly as
in the insect the meaning comes from the
metaphor of a fly hovering around a
fruit the way a man or woman hovers
around their desired partner
another word of mapo moon origin is
which means little or short in the sense
of quantity like poco
i have little juice left this comes from
the maputhangun word piccintun
the word for belly
me
this means my belly hurts or i have a
stomachache
the word meaning gossip
i've got some gossip to tell you this
word comes from the maputhalun word
kawin meaning party the word was used to
refer to a type of meeting where the
heads of different tribes gather
together to discuss various issues
concerning their region but also to
socialize and gossip that's why it's now
used with the meaning of gossip
there's also chilean spanish slang as
you might expect some of it's used in
other latin american countries as well
such as magan this means cool or awesome
in addition to chile it's also used in
ecuador peru colombia and cuba
this car is cool
i had a great time at the beach where i
had a fun time at the beach
but some slang is specifically chilean
altitude this means right now or right
away
come to my house right now
it's used with an imperative or with an
answer to an imperative it literally
means as the shot is fired so it's like
saying as fast as a bullet
yeah in general spanish this means now
in chilean slang it's used as an answer
to a command and it shows agreement in a
similar way to okay for example this
exchange meaning do your homework okay
okay let's do this in this case it's
used as an answer to a command
this means boring
the movie was pretty boring
this idiom literally means to do dead
dog this is a uniquely chilean idiom
meaning to leave a restaurant without
paying your portion of the bill
i invited my friend out to eat but he
did dead dog on me
this idiom means to skip class
i skipped class yesterday
this word is used at the end of a
sentence to emphatically express
certainty or make an assertion this
corresponds with pues in general spanish
sipo yes of course nopo no way
well let's go then
this car is faster man
this comes from the english verb to
catch it means different things
depending on where it's placed in a
sentence and the context in which it's
used it's used in chile as well as
argentina and bolivia
the imperative forms kacha and kachen
mean look or listen and are used as a
way to grab the attention of the
listener they usually appear at the
beginning of the sentence
look at that car
listen today i went to the mall
cachaste is used kind of like did you
know or did you notice did you see or
haven't you heard basically checking if
you're aware of something
did you know that i went to the mall
today
is used at the end of a sentence to
check that the other person is still
following what you're saying much like
right and it functions as a filler you
don't need to respond to it
today i went to the mall right
it's also used with the meaning of catch
or find out
they caught me
as you can see chilean spanish is a
special and unique variety of spanish in
many ways it's similar to latin american
spanish in general especially the
varieties of the southern cone of south
america but it also has its own unique
features vocabulary and slang when
chileans speak formally and avoid using
specifically chilean features their
speech is known for sounding
particularly pleasant and neutral some
people say this is because chileans are
very aware of how their dialects differ
from others and they're used to
adjusting their speech to make it
understandable for other people and they
even have to do that within chile
because there are various varieties of
speech that differ depending on location
and socioeconomic background the
question of the day to native speakers
of chilean spanish to what extent do you
use the chilean features mentioned in
the video does it depend on the
situation and to other spanish speakers
what's your impression of chilean
spanish and how well can you communicate
with people from chile
if you want to improve your spanish i
recommend you check out spanish pod 101
their course consists of thousands of
user-friendly lessons broken down into
playlists based on level and topic so
you can focus on exactly what you need
to learn i'm currently using pod 101
courses for two other languages and i
especially like using their intermediate
and advanced audio lessons to practice
shadowing and to improve my listening
comprehension to sign up for a free
lifetime account click the link in the
description or visit langfocus.com
spanishpod and right now it's time to
say thanks to all the langfocus patreon
supporters especially the ones whose
names appear right here on the screen
they are the top tier patreon supporters
so many extra special thanks go out to
them check out
patreon.comlangfocus to find out how you
can become a patron too and everyone
thank you for watching and have a nice
day
[Music]
you